zendaya and Tom Holland may be more than
friends after all
and Justin Bieber's holiday thirst trap
plus we're taking you inside Taylor
Swift's reputation pop up hey friends
welcome back to the daily Benny now my
spidey senses are tingling because
despite public denials looks like
spider-man Home Coming co-stars India
and Tom Holland are an item a source
tells et they are really connected and
they've been keeping their relationship
under the radar for privacy reasons so
here's the deal the two were first
reported to be dating back in July
during the spider-man press tour but
both shut that down zendaya told variety
that tom was one of her best friends now
shortly after I was in there myself
about being linked to her co-star here's
what she told me you know I love that
you're so open about those pesky dating
rumors or Tom Holland in this issue why
was inappropriate bill hey guys come on
it's like my best friend have you found
that it's hard to date Hollywood oh yeah
it's such a young age you know where you
are either I mean it's just hard to date
in general you know sometimes it's hard
to you know find people that you really
click with or really understand you and
add on top of the fact that my lifestyle
is very different so I mean it's it's
tough but she's chilling all right now
having spoke to both of them during the
spider-man junket they clearly have a
great friendship and shouldn't that be
the foundation of every solid
relationship now one thing is for sure
Tom got one stylish lady on his arm
I mean look at her right here she looks
so good Linda has been turning heads on
her latest press tour and turning the
greatest showmen tour into a frigging
fashion runway from bolt pattern's
90s supermodel chic to hot pink gaucho
pants this girl slays me probably the
best-dressed female of 2017 can I get a
Slayer nay if you agree or disagree let
me know in the comments now I mean while
someone was not even gonna bother with
clothes justin bieber christmas came
early for all you believers because
justin deck the halls' shirtless
on Thursday Bebe's got into the holiday
spirit decorating his Christmas treats
and shirt he shared this time-lapse
video on Instagram set to Jingle Bell
Rock of course justin has a lot to
celebrate these days including his
rekindled relational goal mez Selena pop
back up on Instagram yesterday in fact
to which bestie Taylor Swift a happy
birthday writing I'm glad you were born
I wish someone knew how big your heart
actually is Taylor's heart is big all
right especially when it comes to love
for her fans because Swifty's get a
chance to check out exclusive reputation
merch and installations at her la pop up
here in Los Angeles of course we had to
send Taylor's number one stand our very
own Katy Krauss to check it out Katy
Denny this Taylor Swift reputation
pop-up store is no joke me and the quad
are out here having the best time and
we're gonna give you a little tour one
question are you ready
[Applause]
tailors pop up is part of her multi-year
deal with AT&T and is located at Santa
Monica's 3rd Street Promenade so I got
in line yesterday so Monday at 8 p.m.
literally the line was completely empty
and I was like here I'm gonna say I'm
not gonna move is it everything that you
dreams it would be everything and more
everything yes yes everything and more
how many people does it take to put
together this pop-up shop there's many
people behind the scenes working on this
for many months how instrumental is
Taylor Swift in this process
oh very Anna the journey continues right
the journey I've Taylor Swift now on the
making of a song it all continues it
doesn't stop now the Grand Tour one
question are you ready
inside you can check out key staples
from her music videos like the look what
you made me do throne and the birdcage a
new edition the New York pop up didn't
tap the LA location also features this
Hollywood inspired reputation wall and
this custom la snake keychain
there's only 250 of them available I
think that's what we wanted to bring
that a little personal
souvenir for LA so people could walk
away with do you know how many cat
mannequins are in here 10 10 to 12
it was style then we have an independent
specialist that comes along with us for
the tour
she's such such great art that she puts
on all these mannequins you can also
watch all the episodes of her series at
the making of a song in the lounge while
enjoying cookies and refreshments and
let me tell you the Swifty's will be out
in full force through the weekend what
is it about Taylor that you think
resonates with so many people I think
it's just I liked her lyrics there's
just a personal and you know Taylor
sniff is like our Bob Dylan of our
generation thanks Katie you guys are now
late Taylor's pop-up shop runs through
December 16th alright guys come back
tomorrow for another dose of daily Denny
and next week we'll be giving you guys
some special end-of-the-year videos
breaking down the best and biggest
moments of the year so be sure you're
following the daily Denny and I'll see
you guys tomorrow
[Music]